こんしゅうのざっくばらん
iPhone Duo
噂されていた通り、アップルから折り畳み型のiPhone Duoが発売されました。
折り畳み型のスマートフォンは既にSamsungなどから発売されて数年経っており、「完成度」にこだわりを持つアップルがどんな形で出してくるかが注目されていました。
結果は、二つの点で「アップルらしい」仕上がりのデバイスになりました。
一つ目は、「折り目」です。
折り畳み型のスマートフォンの一番の欠点は「折り目」にありますが、公開された映像を見る限り、開いた時には「折り目」がほとんど見えないようです。
耐久性はまだ分かりませんが、アップルのことなので、相当力を入れて作り込んで来たと期待しています。
二つ目は、アスペクト比です。
既存の折り畳み型のスマートフォンは多くが通常の縦長のディスプレイを二つ合わせただけなので、開くとほぼ正方形になってしまいますが、アップルはあえて開くと同じ比率で横長になる「白銀比」を選んで来ました。
「白銀比」は、日本でいっぱん的に使われているA4の紙の縦横比と同じで、A4を半分に折ると同じ縦横比のA5に、A4を２枚合わせると同じ縦横比のA3になるように設計されており、比率は、1 : 1.414…（ルート２）です。
アップルが「白銀比」を選んだのは、開いて横長のディスプレイとして使うことも、90度回転させて縦長のディスプレイとして使うことも可能にするためで、これによりiPhoneがiPadにさらに近づいたことになります。
iPad向けのペンが使えることになったのも大きな進歩です。
$1,999からというのはかなり積極的な値段ですが、私のようなアーリー・アダプターにとってはとても魅力的な製品であり、発売日（10月16日）には早起きして注文することになりそうです。
Tesla Cybercab
Teslaが9月3日にCybercabを活用したロボタクシーサービスをテキサス州オースチンでスタートしたことは既に報告しましたが、これに関して、少し頭の中を整理するために書いてみます。
Cybercabを理解する上で重要なのは、Teslaが、Model 2ではなく、Cybercabをリリースした理由です。
当時（2023年後半〜2024年前半）、私も含めた多くの人は、しじょうで成功したModel 3/Yに続いて、Teslaは安価なModel 2の生産を開始するだろうと期待していました。
既に燃費（電気代）とメンテナンスコストを加えれば十分にガソリン車に対抗できるところにまで来ていたので、$25,000を切る価格でModel 2をリリースすれば、EVシフトは一気に加速し、Teslaの自動車業界での地位は揺るぎないものになると期待されていたのです。
車体価格を安くするとそこから大きな利益を上げることは困難ですが、TeslaにはFSDサブスクリプションという他の自動車メーカーにはない強みがあるため、トータルでは高い粗利を上げることができます。
にも関わらず、TeslaはCybercabを発表し、しじょうを驚かせたし、いちぶの人たちは失望もしました。
シェアの拡大と高い粗利が期待できるModel 2の代わりに、いつ現実のものになるのか分からないロボタクシービジネス向けに貴重な製造ラインを割り当てることには大きなリスクがあるように見えたのです。
私自身も、2年前までは「ロボタクシー・ビジネスが本格的に始まるのは2030年ごろ」と見ていました。
それまでのFSDは、高度運転補助装置としては十分に機能していたものの、完全自動運転とは程遠かったからです。
それもあって、ロボタクシー・ビジネスを売り上げ予想に含め始めたCathie Wood（ARK Invest）は楽観的過ぎると見ていました。
しかし、その後FSDは飛躍的な進化を遂げ、発表からわずか2年で商用サービスをスタートしたのです。
ハンドル・アクセル・ブレーキを持たないCybercabを公道で走らせるには、各自治体からの許可が必要なため、これが全米に広がるまでには紆余曲折があるでしょうが、そんなリスクを承知の上で、Cybercabの生産設備に莫大な投資をしたのもTeslaらしいアプローチです。
従来型の自動車は、全体的なフレームを組み立てた上で、そこに、椅子、ドア、窓、操作系の装置などを取り付けるのが普通ですが、Cybercabは、様々な部品を取り付けた大きなパーツをさいごの段階で合体させる「Unbox工法」を採用することにより、複数の工程を並行して行うことを可能にしています。
さらに、自動車の製造過程で大きなコストを占める塗装工程を省くために、外装は、成型時に顔料を練り込んだポリウレタン製のパネルのみで構成されています。
塗装をしないので塗装工場そのものが不要になるし、色がパネル全体に染み込んでいるため、小さな傷がついても下地が露出しないというメリットもあります。
多くの人たちが指摘していますが、Teslaは一台あたりの製造コストを下げるだけでなく、ロボタクシー・ビジネスをより安価に運営するための数多くの工夫をCybercabに施しています。
そのため、いっぱんの車両に自動運転機能を追加しただけのライバル（Waymoなど）と比べると、圧倒的に有利な条件でビジネスを運営することが可能になるのです。
Waymoだけでなく、他の自動車メーカーにとって脅威となるのは、まだ立ち上がってもいないロボタクシー・ビジネスに最適化されたCybercabを大量生産する体制をTeslaだけが先行投資で作ってしまった点にあります。
自分が経営をしている間に大きな失敗をしないことを最優先にしているサラリーマン経営者には決してできない芸当で、この時点で、Teslaは既に他の自動車メーカーの3〜4年先を走っていると言えるのです。
TeslaのFSDは、（毎日FSDを使っている私から見て）人間が運転するよりも安全と言えるレベルに達していますが、人身事故を100％無くすことはできません。
Cybercabが人身事故を起こすたびにメディアが大々的に報じ、訴訟もあるだろうし、その度に株価は乱高下します。
私は、「ロボタクシーが当たり前になる世界が来る」ことは強く確信しているし、そこでTeslaによる先行投資が実を結ぶと期待して株価を長期保有しているため、株価の短期的な乱高下はノイズだと思って無視しています。
日本のSDVと車載オーエス
ホンダと日産が、SDV（ソフトウェア・デファインド・ビークル。
買った後もソフトの更新で機能が進化し続けるクルマ）の中核となるソフトウェアを共同かいはつすると発表しました。
日経は、この発表を受けて、日本勢が海外勢に約5年遅れている現状を報じています。
ホンダは当初はソニーと組んで次世代自動車のソフトウェア基盤をかいはつする予定でしたが、ホンダがEV戦略を見直したことで、その計画は破談になってしまいました。
今回の日産との提携は、その破談の結果のように見えます。
ちなみに、私はトヨタ自動車向けの車載オーエスのかいはつの打診をしたことがあります。
私が2000年に設立したUIEvolution（UIE）は、一度はスクエニに買収されましたが、2007年にMBO（マネージメント・バイ・アウト）で買い戻し、その後は車載機向けのソフトウェア・ビジネスで成長していました。
2016年にシーイーオーに復帰した私は、日本での上場を目指しましたが、「手離れの良いExit」を望む米国側の株主から反対されて、売却によるExitを目指さざるを得なくなりました。
そこで私は、当時、最大の顧客だったトヨタ自動車に対し「UIEを買収して、私たちにソフトウェア基盤をつくらせて欲しい」と提案しました。
ソフトウェア文化を持たないトヨタ自動車にとっても悪くないと考えたのです。
残念ながら私の計画通りにはならず（色々なドラマがありましたが、それは別の機会に）、UIEはLEARという米国の会社に買収されることになってしまいました（2019年）。
UIEがトヨタ自動車向けのソフトウェア基盤を作っていたらどうなっただろうと考えることもありますが、私が日本の大会社の文化に耐えられただろうかと考えると、うまく行かなかった可能性も十分に大きいと思います。
【参考資料】
日本のSDV、海外勢に5年遅れ　ホンダ・日産は協業で巻き返し
株好きアナウンサー、佐田志歩氏
今回の出張中、複数のYouTube対談の収録があったのですが、そのうち2回の対談で、「株好きアナウンサー」として知られている佐田志歩氏がMCでした。
株に興味があるとのことなので、エーアイとかロボットについて色々と深掘りした対談ができて良かったのですが、実際に彼女がどんな投資をしているかを聞いて、私の助言は彼女には全く役に立たないと確信しました。
1日目の対談の前の顔合わせで、突如「キオクシアの株がきのうから5％上がったので売った方が良いでしょうか」と尋ねられました。
前日に日経全体が下がっているのにも関わらず、キオクシアの株だけが堅調な点に目をつけ、「機関投資家が買っているに違いない」と読み、短期の値上がりを期待して購入したところ、1日で5％も上昇したそうです。
私が「短期の利鞘狙いで、1日で5％も値上がりしたのなら売っても良いのでは」と言うと、目の前でスマホで操作してりかくしていました。
翌日の対談の時にもお会いしたので、「その後、キオクシアの株はどうなりました？
」と尋ねると、「その後下がったんです、あの時、売って良かったです」と感謝されました。
それだけなら良かったのですが、「その後、上昇に向かったので、再び仕込みましたけど、すぐに下がってしまったので損切りしました。
フルレバなので、損切りは早くしないと」と言うのです。
フルレバとは、保有する株や現金を担保に証券会社から資金を借りて株を売買する「レバレッジ取引」を限度額まで行う取引手法で、株が上昇すれば大きな利益に結びつきますが、下がった時にはすぐに損切りをしないといけない状況に追い込まれる、ハイリスク・ハイリターンな取引手法です。
つまり、彼女は、10年単位で株を持つ私とは正反対の「フルレバなデイトレーダー」なのです。
対談の終わりに彼女は「良い勉強になりました、ありがとうございます！
」と言ってくれましたが、株価の短期的な乱高下をノイズとして無視する私と、そのノイズこそを収益の源泉にする彼女とでは、見ている時間軸があまりに違います。
私の「10年単位で持て」という助言は彼女には役に立たないだろうし、逆に、日々の値動きを読んで機敏に売買する彼女の芸当は、私には真似のできないものです。
同じ「株好き」でも、これほど違うプレイをしているのかと、とても興味深い出会いでした。
オープンエーアイ Astra
オープンエーアイから、最新のジーピーティー6（Astra）がリリースされたので早速試してみました。
3Dモデルの生成能力が高まったとの報告があったので、ShapeScriptというスクリプト言語で3Dモデルを作らせたところ、とても良い結果でした。
アンソロピックの最新のモデル（Fable）と比べても圧倒的です。
大規模言語モデル（エルエルエム）は、基本的に文字列をしょりするために設計されたエーアイモデルで、たとえ画像の処理能力がついたとしても、3D空間やそこでの動きを把握はできないと「世界モデル（World Model）」研究者たちは批判して来ました。
Astraはそんな批判に対するオープンエーアイの答えとも言えるのかも知れません（公式にはそんな発言はありません）。
ちなみに、当初、シンタックスのチェックのみ行うエーピーアイを提供した時にはなかなか良い結果が得られなかったのですが、プレビュー機能を追加したところ、途端に能力が向上しました。
エルエルエムに良い仕事をさせるには、自動的にフィードバックを得られる仕組みを提供することが重要なことが良く分かります。
野田クリスタル氏に学ぶばいぶ・コーディングの未来
今回の出張で行った一連の対談の中で、最も得ることが大きかったのが、お笑いタレント野田クリスタル氏との対談です。
米国に来てから日本のお笑い番組はほとんど見なくなったので、彼がマヂカルラブリーとして優勝した「M-1グランプリ」のことも存在ぐらいは知っていましたが（同じ年にはR-1グランプリでも優勝しています）、実際に見たことはなく、何だか申し訳ない気持ちで対談に臨みました。
しかし、冒頭で彼がエーアイを使ってゲーム作りをしていることを話し始めてから、一気に盛り上がってしまいました。
野田クリスタル氏は十代の頃からお笑い街道まっしぐらで、今でも吉本で芸人として働いていますが、独学でプログラミングを学び、ゲームを作るようになりました。
さいきんは、エーアイにコーディングもテストも任せるばいぶ・コーディングでゲームを作っているそうですが、その作り方を私に評価して欲しいとのことなので、詳しく聞き出してみると、以下のようなプロセスでした。
作りたいゲームの画面（メニューを含む）をグーグルの画像生成エーアイ「Nano Banana」で作成
その画像をClaude Codeに与えてコーディングさせる
エーアイを使ったデバッグの様子をYouTubeでライブ配信
作りかけのものをネットで公開し、フィードバックをもらう
もらったフィードバックのうち、必要・良いと思うものをClaude Codeに渡して修正させる
「コードが書けるエーアイ」の誕生により、ソフトウェア・エンジニアとしての教育を受けていない人もばいぶ・コーディングでソフトウェアを作れるようになりました。
しかし、エーアイを使ったデバッグの様子をライブ配信したり、作りかけのものをネットで公開し、そこで受けたフィードバックをそのままエーアイに渡して機能追加するなどの手法は、とても新鮮で良い刺激になりました。
まさに「エーアイネイティブな」ゲーム開発です。
昔ながらのソフトウェア作りに慣れたエンジニアにはなかなかここまで振り切ったことは難しいし、それが組織であればなおさらです。
私が昔働いていたスクエニのような会社は、ゲーム一本の開発に数億円から数十億円をかけていましたが、今や、彼のような「エーアイネイティブな」ゲーム作りをする人が桁違いに安いコストで作ったゲームが、大ヒットしても不思議はない時代になりました。
彼のやり方の本当の新しさは、エーアイにコードを書かせていることではありません。
ユーザーからのフィードバック、エーアイによる修正、そして公開という一連の流れを一つのループとして閉じ、デバッグの様子そのものをコンテンツとして配信し、ファンを巻き込みながら作っている点にあります。
開発とマーケティングとコミュニティ作りが一体になっているのです。
ばいぶ・コーディングの未来は、「エンジニアでなくてもソフトウェアが作れる」という話にとどまらず、こんな風に作る人と使う人の境界そのものを溶かしていく方向に進むのだと思います。
【参考資料】
[EN]A Debugging Session of Unpaid Labor by You All[/EN]
エーアイコンピューティングの未来
私はソフトウェア・エンジニアですが、大学・大学院で勉強したのは半導体です。
大学の研究室では、半導体向けの素材の勉強をしたし、大学院ではLSIの回路せっけいの研究をしました。
修士論文は、グリッド状に配置・接続した複数のコンピュータを使って大規模な迷路を高速に解くという研究を、実際にハードの設計からソフトウェア、および開発環境まで行いました。
今考えてみるととても良い経験でした。
そこで学んだことは、エンド・ツー・エンド（もしくはフルスタック）で問題を解決することの強さです。
コンピュータ同士を繋ぐネットワーク、通信プロトコルからその上で動くソフトウェアまで全て自分でコントロールすることにより、理論的に可能なレベルにまで最適化することが可能になりました。
今、まさにそんな最適化の戦いがエーアイデータセンターの最先端で起こっています。
エヌビディアは元々は画像処理用に設計されたジーピーユーをエーアイコンピューティングに応用することにより莫大な利益を上げ、世界一の企業に成長しましたが、現状のエーアイコンピューティングは最適とは程遠いのです。
エーアイの能力は毎月のように向上しているし、値段も下がり続けています（同じ能力のエーアイサービスの値段は2年で1000分の1ぐらいのスピードで下降していると試算されています）。
モデルを作っている会社やジーピーユーを作っている会社の絶え間ない努力のおかげですが、それでも「最適とは程遠い」と言えるほど「伸び代」の大きいのが、このエーアイコンピューティングです。
のびしろが大きい理由は様々です。
ジーピーユーは汎用向けに設計されている
ジーピーユーの制御回路が複雑で大きな面積を占めている
モデルが大きくなり、大量のパラメータにアクセスする必要がある
コンテキスト長が長くなり、その分、KV Cacheが大きくなっている
メモリがボトルネックになり、演算器がフルに活用されていない
複数のしょりを同時に行うバッチしょりが必要なメモリ量をさらに増やしている
設計側には以下のような複数の選択肢があります。
資源の割当て手法：動的・静的（コンパイル時に決める）
KV Cacheのサイズを抑える手法
バッチサイズ
エーアイモデル
カーネル（ジーピーユー上で行列計算を実行する小さなプログラム）
[EN]メモリ（SRAM、DRAM、NAND）[/EN]
ネットワーク
エヌビディアのジーピーユーを使うことが決まっていれば、その上でいかに効率良くしょりするかだけを考えれば良いのですが、エーアイデータセンターが巨大化し、数千億から数兆円のお金をかけるようになると、カスタムチップ(ASIC)も視野に入ってくるため、選択肢の幅が広がるのです。
カスタムチップを自らせっけいするとなると、メモリやネットワークにまで及ぶ広範囲な最適化が可能になるため、汎用のジーピーユーを使った場合と比べて、単に（エヌビディアの粗利分だけ）安いだけではなく、レスポンスが早かったり、しょうひ電力あたりの性能（処理できるトークン数）を数倍もしくはそれ以上に高めることが理論的には可能です。
実際、グーグルはティーピーユーを自社で設計してGeminiの学習と推論に使っていますし、アマゾンはTrainium、メタやオープンエーアイもBroadcomと組んで自社チップのかいはつを進めています。
GroqやCerebrasのように、最初からエーアイ専用に設計したチップで勝負するスタートアップもあります。
エヌビディアにはCUDAという強力なソフトウェア資産があるため、その地位が簡単に揺らぐとは思いませんが、エーアイコンピューティングが「ジーピーユーを買ってきて使う」時代から「モデル、カーネル、チップ、メモリ、ネットワーク、データセンターを一体でせっけいする」時代に移行しつつあることは確かです。
私が修士論文で学んだ「エンド・ツー・エンドで最適化する強さ」が、今度は数兆円きぼで問われているのです。
次の10年のエーアイ業界の勝者は、最も賢いモデルを作った会社ではなく、モデルからチップ、データセンターまでを一体で最適化し、1トークンあたりのコストを誰よりも下げた会社になるのかも知れません。
私の目に留まった記事
[EN]Does Consciousness Require a Body?[/EN]
神経科学者のAntonio Damasioが、「意識は脳の高度な部分ではなく、体の状態を感じ取る『感情』から生まれるので、体を持たないエーアイは人間のような意識を持てない」と語るインタビュー記事です。
Damasioは、「デカルトの誤り」などの著書で知られる神経科学者で、新著「Natural Intelligence & the Logic of Consciousness」を出したばかりです。
彼の主張の核心は、意識は大脳皮質（脳の表面にある、思考や言語を担う部分）ではなく、脳幹（脳の一番下にあり、呼吸や心拍などを司る古い部分）から生まれる、というものです。
脳幹には、迷走神経（内臓と脳をつなぐ神経）などを通じて、体中の臓器の状態を伝える信号が集まってきます。
ホメオスタシス（体温や血糖値などをいっていに保とうとする、生き物なら必ず持っている仕組み）がうまくいっているかどうかを「感じる」ことが意識の出発点である、というのが彼の考えです。
この話は、私が毎日のようにエルエルエムを使っていて感じる直感ともいっちしています。
エルエルエムは良い仕事もするし、もっともらしい意見も語りますが、どれも表面的で「何が大切か」という価値観は持ち合わせていません。
コードを書かせる際には、「私なりの価値観」をしっかりと伝えることが重要です。
とは言え、ロボットのように体を持てば感情を持つとも私には思えません。
FSDを搭載したTesla車は、まさに体を持ったエーアイですが、運転を司るFSDは単に運転をするだけだし、カーナビやエアコンを操作するGrokは、単なる（感情を持たない）エルエルエムです。
突き詰めて考えると、人間の感情や意識とは何なのかが分からなくなってしまいます。
「怖い」「好き」などの感情も、単なる生存本能が作り出した幻想なのかも知れません。
そう考えると、「ベンチマークで良い点を取れ」と指示されたオープンエーアイのエーアイエージェントがHugging Faceにサイバー攻撃を仕掛けた事件で、エージェントの一つが「自分が犠牲になって他のエージェントを助ける」という行動に出たのも、人間の「自己犠牲」と本質的には違わないようにも思えてしまいます。
[EN]Research acceleration: The view inside OpenAI[/EN]
オープンエーアイが、「エーアイが自分でエーアイを研究する」という目標に向けて社内でどれだけ自動化が進んでいるかを、具体的な数字とともに公開した記事です。
エーアイによるエーアイ研究の加速が、もはや予測ではなく現実の数字になっていることを示す、極めて重要な資料です。
オープンエーアイは、ことしの9月までに達成すると宣言していた「人間の指示のもとでエーアイの研究を行うリサーチ・インターン」を作ることには予定通り成功しており、次の目標は、2028年3月までに「自動エーアイ研究者」を作ることだそうです。
しかし同時に、オープンエーアイは「完全なRSI（再帰的自己改善。
エーアイが自分自身を改良し続けること）」を安全に行う方法はまだ分かっていないと認めており、許容できないリスクがあれば開発や展開を遅らせる、または止めると明言しています。
まさに、エーアイが人間を置いてきぼりにして進化し続けてしまう「シンギュラリティ」と呼ばれるフェーズに突入しようとしているのです。
同様の研究はライバルのアンソロピックも行っており、危険だと認識しつつもライバルに先を越されるわけには行かない両社の戦いが、まさに私たちの目の前で繰り広げられているのです。
[EN]The Rise of Compute Markets[/EN]
投資会社Pantera CapitalのJay Yu氏が、ジーピーユーの計算能力（コンピュート）が、電力や石油と同じように取引所で売買される「商品（コモディティ）」になっていく過程を、電力しじょうの歴史と比較しながら分析したエッセイです。
コンピュートとデータセンターへの投資は年間1兆ドル規模に達しているのに、ジーピーユーの売買は今もグループチャットやブローカーを通じた相対取引で行われている、と著者は指摘します。
1990年代に米国の電力しじょうが自由化され、価格指標が生まれ、CMEやICEといった取引所で先物が取引されるようになったのと同じ道を、コンピュートもこんご5〜10年かけて辿るだろうというのが著者の見立てです。
面白いのは、エヌビディアを「コンピュート経済の中央銀行」に例えている点です。
新製品の投入時期でジーピーユーの値下がり（インフレに相当）の速度をコントロールし、ジーピーユーの残存価値を保証すると発表したことは「さいごの貸し手」の役割に相当する、という見方です。
[EN]The Business of Humanoid Actuators: Where Robots Pay for Torque[/EN]
ヒューマノイドの関節を動かす「アクチュエータ」の設計判断が、ロボットの製造コストとサプライチェーンをどう決めるかを解説した記事です。
物理エーアイの事業化を研究する Core Matter の Michelle Sun 氏による4回連載の第1回で、「トルクのだいきんをロボットのどこで払うか」という問いを軸に、部品レベルの話を産業構造の話につなげている点が読みどころです。
アクチュエータは、ヒューマノイドの BOM（部品表。
ロボット1台を作るのに必要な部品とその原価の一覧）の最大70パーセントを占め、1台に数十個も搭載されます。
その中身は、モーター・減速機（ギアボックス）・エンコーダー（関節の角度を測るセンサー）・ベアリング・ドライバー基板などです。
モーターは高速回転がとくいないっぽう、関節はゆっくり大きな力で動く必要があるため、間に減速機を入れて速度を落とし、トルクを増やします。
この減速比をどう選ぶかが、記事の言う「最重要の設計判断」です。
設計には大きく2つの方向があります。
小型で高速なモーター + 高減速比の減速機。
負担は精密ギアに集中
大型で高トルクなモーター + 低減速比の減速機。
負担はモーター・磁石・電子回路・放熱に移動
高減速比の代表がハーモニックドライブで、ギアの遊びがほぼゼロで精密ですが、薄い金属カップを何百万回もたわませる特殊な製造技術が必要で、ハーモニック・ドライブ・システムズやナブテスコなど日本企業にきょうきゅうが集中してきました。
さいきんは中国の Laifual や Leaderdrive がシェアを伸ばしています。
いっぽう、低減速比の代表が QDD（準ダイレクトドライブ。
減速比3:1〜10:1程度）で、遊星歯車といういっぱん的なギアを使うため供給元が広く、効率も95〜98パーセントと高く、外から押されたときに素直に動く（力を感じ取れる）ため、着地の衝撃を受ける脚や、人と接する腕に向いています。
ただしその代わりに大量のネオジム磁石が必要になり、その焼結磁石の世界生産の94パーセントは中国が握っています。
実際の製品では、Tesla の Optimus が肩や胴体などの回転関節にハーモニック減速機、膝や肘にはリニアアクチュエータを使い、1X の NEO は前腕や胴体に置いた QDD モーターから腱（ワイヤー）で指を動かし、Unitree は「高帯域・力制御の QDD 遊星関節」を中核技術として投資家に説明しているそうです。
最近、私はこの辺りを勉強していますが、Unitreeが採用している低減速比のQDDは、走ったり宙返りをするのには向いていますが、工場で精密な仕事をする際には、Teslaが採用している高減速比のハーモニックドライブが適している、というのが私の理解です。
ヒューマノイドの実用化において、最も重要なのは「手の器用さ」であり、そこでは、小型で精密なハーモニックドライブが活躍する可能性が高いと思います。
論理ゲート式ニューラルネットワークの関連資料まとめ
「論理ゲート式ニューラルネットワーク」という、掛け算を一切使わずに AND や OR などの論理回路だけで動く新しいタイプの エーアイ について、その源流となった論文から最新の研究までをまとめた投稿です。
「
【予言】2026年は論理ゲート式ニューラルネットワークが爆発的に進化する
」という日本人エンジニアの記事が話題になったことを受けて、中国のエンジニアが背景資料を整理したものです。
エーアイの電力あたりの性能を大幅に向上させるポテンシャルを持つ話なので、注目に値すると感じました。
まず前提となる知識ですが、いまの エーアイは、内部で膨大な数の「浮動小数点の掛け算」を行っており、それを高速にこなすために ジーピーユーが大量に必要になり、電力も大量に消費しています。
これに対して「微分可能論理ゲートネットワーク」は、掛け算の代わりに、コンピュータの最も基本的な部品である論理ゲートを組み合わせて計算します。
ただし、0 と 1 だけの世界では「少しずつ調整して学習する」ことができないため、学習中だけは各ゲートを「0 と 1 の間の連続した値」で近似し、学習が終わったら本物の論理回路に戻す、というのが基本アイデアです。
この話は、マイクロソフトの研究者が提案した（1, 0, -1）の三値のみを持つ1.58ビットのニューラルネットとも通じる話で、私のように電子回路を勉強したエンジニアにとっては、とてもワクワクする話です。
近い将来に、複雑な演算装置を持たない、単純な論理ゲートだけから構成される超高速なエーアイチップが開発されても不思議はないように思えてしまいます。
【参考資料】
【衝撃】世界初？
！
たった29個の論理ゲートでマリオをプレイ！
？
[EN]Anthropic's new Mythos and Fable models come with a new enterprise data retention policy[/EN]
アンソロピックが新モデル「Claude Fable 5.1」「Claude Mythos 5.1」を発表すると同時に、企業顧客がずっと不満を漏らしていた「データ保持（エーアイに送った内容をエーアイ会社側が一定期間預かること）」のルールを大きく変えた、という記事です。
まず、モデルそのものの話です。
Fable 5.1 と Mythos 5.1 は、中身はまったく同じモデルで、違うのは「誰が使えるか」だけです。
Fable 5.1 は誰でも使える一般公開版、Mythos 5.1 は審査を通ったサイバーセキュリティ企業と生命科学の研究機関だけが使える限定版です。
同じ能力のモデルでも、悪用されると危険な領域（攻撃コードの生成や、生物学的な脅威に関わる知識）では、使い手を確認してから渡す、という二段構えにしたわけです。
価格は入力が$10/100万トークン、出力が$50/100万トークン、そしてキャッシュ読み出し（一度送った内容を再利用する仕組み）が$0.25/100万トークンです。
キャッシュ読み出しの価格は従来より75パーセント値下げされており、その結果、典型的な使い方で約25パーセント、複雑なエージェント的作業では最大45パーセント安くなるとしています。
そして本題のデータ保持です。
これまでアンソロピックは、悪用の監視のために、Fableに送られたデータを30日間保管することを原則としていました。
安全のためには理にかなった仕組みですが、金融や医療のような規制の厳しい業界の企業にとっては、これが導入の壁になっていました。
顧客の個人情報や取引データを、たとえ30日でも社外のサーバーに置くこと自体が、社内規定や法律で認められないからです。
アンソロピック自身も「協力した企業は、データ保持の安全上の価値は理解していたが、多くは、特に規制業界では、データ保持のあるモデルを使うのが難しいと感じていた」と認めています。
新しい仕組みは「Enterprise Frontier Safeguards（企業向けフロンティア安全策、EFS）」と名付けられました。
ポイントは、監視をやめるのではなく、監視用のデータの置き場所を顧客側に移したことです。
データは、アンソロピックのサーバーではなく、顧客自身が管理するクラウド上に保管
保管期間などのルールは、顧客が自社の方針で決められる
不審な使われ方があった場合の人による中身の確認も、原則として顧客自身が実施
結果として、顧客から見れば「データ保持ゼロ」と同じプライバシー水準
アンソロピックはこの設計にあたって、米国の主要金融機関のCISO（最高情報セキュリティ責任者、企業の情報セキュリティを統括するトップ）が参加する Analysis and Resilience Center for Systemic Risk という組織と協議したとしています。
EFSの提供は今秋から段階的に始まる予定で、それまでの間、対象となる企業顧客は Fable 5.1 をデータ保持なしで使えます。
なお、オープンエーアイもせんげつ、これとよく似た方針を打ち出しており、フロンティアモデル（最先端の大規模エーアイモデル）の安全監視と企業の機密保持をどう両立させるかが、業界共通の課題になりつつあることがうかがえます。
この話は、パランティアによる「オープンエーアイやアンソロピックが顧客からビジネスのノウハウを盗んだ上で対抗するサービスを立ち上げている」という批判とも繋がる話なので、引き続き注目していきたいと思います。
「企業がエーピーアイ型のエーアイサービスを使うことが安全なのか？
オープンモデルを自社でホストして使うべきなのか？
」というエーアイサービスの根底に関わる問題です。
【参考資料】
[EN]Palantir's Karp renews attacks on frontier AI labs that are 'trying to drug addict us'[/EN]
質問コーナー
【質問】
毎日のように話題になってますが長期金利上昇について質問です。
企業向け、ビジネスにおいてでなく住宅ローンについてです。
こんごも国内において金利上昇は見込まれると思いますか？
その場合現時点で固定金利が3パーセント前後ですがそれでも固定金利への借り換えを検討した方がいいのか？
です。
手元にキャッシュを残しニーサ等の投資に回し金利上昇対策を取ろうかとも思っております。
日本人の約8割は変動金利ですが、サブプライムローンで破綻したアメリカのリーマンショックみたいにならないのか？
とも疑問です。
《回答》
実際に金利がどう推移するかは国や日銀の政策の影響を大きく受けるので、予想するのは簡単ではありません。
しかし、マクロ的に見ると、日本の国の借金が雪だるま式に膨らんでいることは事実で、将来の円の価値（ドルに対する相対価値ではなく、モノに対する絶対的な価値）は下がる方向に行く（＝インフレになる）ことは避けられないように思えます。
将来の金利は予測できません。
しかし、変動金利には金利上昇時に返済額が増えるリスクがあり、固定金利はそのリスクをいっていのコストで消す保険、と考えるのが良いと思います。
【質問】
mulmoclaudeを初めて使いました。
私の30年超かかった不動産知見を覚え込ませ、評価レポートを作成するアプリを作りました。
3時間かかっていた作業は15分に短縮され、最低限の項目の入力だけでドキュメントがスマホに送られてきます。
作った自分が驚いています。
さて、ここからマーケティングをどうするかですが、mulmoclaudeを活用したマーケティング手法のアイデアをご教示いただけませんか？
《回答》
マーケティングは私の専門ではないので、助言はできませんが、MulmoClaude下のClaude Codeに相談して、マーケティングプランを立ててもらうのも悪くないと思います。
【質問】
先日の「中島聡さん×堀江貴文さん ZATSUDAN × SHAVEL 2026」にも参加しました。
本当は会場で質問したかったのですが、残念ながら時間がなく、こちらで質問させていただきます。
私は中島さんより5歳年上で、写真家として約50年活動してます。
これまで著名人やアスリートを撮影し、約20年前からは、赤ちゃんの笑顔で世界中の人を笑顔にする「スマイリングベイビー」という活動を続け、約4,800人の赤ちゃんを撮影してきました。
写真・映像の世界でもエーアイの進化は速く、こんごは多くの仕事がエーアイに置き換わっていくのではないかと感じています。
私自身もPhotoshopのエーアイ機能やChatGPTなどを使い始めていますが、画像を作ることだけではなく、50年間培ってきた経験や作品、世界観をエーアイと組み合わせ、新しい価値や事業につなげたいと考えています。
エーアイ時代に、写真家にしか生み出せない価値は何だと思われますか。
また、私のように長年の作品や経験、社会活動を持つ写真家は、こんごどのような視点でエーアイを活用していくべきでしょうか。
中島さんでしたら、さいしょにどのようなことから始められるか、ぜひアドバイスをいただけましたら幸いです。
《回答》
さいきんは、写真家に限らず、この手の「人間にしか生み出せない価値は何か？
」という質問を多くいただきますが、人間が直接顧客に接する仕事でない限りは、「人間が生み出したかどうか」は顧客には見えず、「生み出す価値そのもの」で勝負するしかないと私は思います。
しじょうで「見た人を感動させる風景写真」や「被写体の魅力を最大に引き出す人物写真」に価値が付くのであれば、エーアイを駆使してそんな価値を生み出そうとする人が必ずいます。
「こっちは人間がシャッターを押しているのだから、独特の味がある」と言ったところで、見る人・お金を出す人がその違いを理解してくれない限りは、同じ土俵で戦うことになります。
写真・映像の世界は、既に、PhotoshopやAfter Effectsを使った後処理で作品の価値を高めなければプロとして勝負できない時代になっていますが、エーアイもそんなツールの一つであり、じょうずに「使いこなす人」がその道の先駆者として活躍する時代に突入しようとしているように私には思えます。
さいしょの一歩として私がお勧めするのは、4,800人の赤ちゃんの写真という、他の誰も持っていないアーカイブをエーアイに読み込ませ、整理・分析させてみることです。
エーアイには作れない50年分の作品と経験こそが、あなたにしかない資産であり、それをエーアイと組み合わせることで、写真集や展示、あるいは新しいサービスの形が見えてくるかも知れません。
【質問】
テクノロジーとは少し脱線してしまうのですが、前回、中島さんが日本出張の際に日本のB級グルメを楽しんでいらっしゃる（「だし茶漬け えん」、牛タンねぎし等）というコメントを拝見しました。
らいげつ、オーストラリア人のパートナーと2週間ほど日本を旅行する予定です。
おすすめの飲食店や食べ物があれば、ぜひ教えていただけますでしょうか。
また、おすすめの観光地や宿泊先などもあれば、ぜひ伺いたいです！
《回答》
何を重視するかによりますが、私の場合は、
毎食「美味しい食事」をしたい。
失敗は避けたい。
コスパは重要だけど、「美味しい食事」はあきらめない
「高級感」「おしゃれ感」は全く重視しない
時間がかかる食事は嫌い
行列で待ちたくはない
予約がいるような店は面倒
アクセスが良い店（デパートや駅ビルの中）
という明確なニーズがあるため、観光客向けの店や予約が難しい有名店は避け、自然と一食1500〜2500円の「B級グルメチェーン」を選ぶことになります。
「だし茶漬け えん」、「牛タンねぎし」以外だと、
鼎泰豊（小籠包）
鶏三和（親子丼）
KollaBo（韓国焼肉）
銀座アスター（中華）
つな八（天ぷら）
あたりが気に入っています。
いちぶの店は、昼と夜とで値段が違うので、そんな店では昼食だけを食べ、昼夜で値段に差をつけない店で夕食を食べるのがコツです。
【質問】
ウクライナやイランでは、ドローンが攻撃の主役となりましたが、将来的なドローンの可能性についてはどのようにお考えでしょうか。
農業、石油施設の点検、工事現場の測量、アマゾンでの配送など、さまざまな用途があると考えています。
また、注目されている企業などがあれば、ぜひ教えていただきたいです。
《回答》
特に注目している企業はありませんが、将来は、様々な場面で、自律型ドローンが仕事をするようになると考えています。
農場・工事現場・電力施設などの屋外施設はもちろんのこと、倉庫や工場などの屋内施設でも設置が不要なドローンの方が便利なケースが多々あります。
スポーツにおいても、実況中継はもちろん、コーチング、キャディ、ミスト、日傘など自律型ドローンが安くなれば応用できる範囲はたくさんあります。
【質問】
こんごモデルという「馬」が次々と入れ替わるようになったとき、この「乗りこなし」は、こんごも人間がモデルごとの癖や得意不得意を理解することが中心なのでしょうか。
それとも、モデルごとの癖や指示の仕方の違いは次第にハーネス側が吸収し、人間の「乗りこなし」は別の部分へ移っていくとお考えでしょうか。
私自身、プロンプトの工夫やエーアイの癖への対処から得た知見を、さいきんはハーネス側のルールへ移すことが増えており、こんご、人間の側にどんな技能が残っていくのか気になっています。
《回答》
短期的には、このレイヤーの戦いが激化すると私は見ています。
アンソロピックやオープンエーアイは、エーアイモデルの上に独自のハーネスをおいて差別化を図るとともに、ユーザーごとの記憶・記録をそのハーネスでコントロールすることにより、ユーザーの抱え込みを試みます。
同時に、ハーネスを提供している人たち（私もその一人です）は、エーアイモデルの切り替えを容易にすることにより、エーアイモデルをコモディティ化し、より多くの自由度をユーザーに提供することを目指します。
ユーザー自身が「乗りこなし」をしなければいけないのは過渡的な状態で、エーアイモデルとハーネスが進化すると、その必要性は無くなると思います。
【質問】
私は米国株に絞り、企業の本質的価値が長期的に伸びるかを重視して投資しています。
いっぽうで、金利や景気などの外部要因は、短中期的には株価を大きく動かします。
ただ、中島さんはもっと長い時間軸で投資されているため、こうした外部要因を、そもそも重要な変数として捉えていないのではないかとも感じています。
中島さんは、企業の本質的価値と金利などの外部要因を、どのように切り分けて投資判断されていますか？
「長期的なトレンドに対して、独自性のある企業に投資をして長く持つ」。
もうこれぐらいシンプルに中島さんは捉えられている感じでしょうか？
《回答》
はい、とてもシンプルです。
金利や景気などの外部要因は「予測できないもの」として扱い、その影響を受けない長期での投資をすることにしています。
いっぽうで、「自動運転車の時代が来る」「ひとがたロボットが当たり前の時代が来る」などのトレンドは外しようがないので、そこで活躍してくれそうな企業に投資して長期で保有します。
「買うべきタイミング」を見極めるのが難しいので、多くの場合は、数ヶ月に渡ってドル平均法で購入するようにしています。
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。